Mora just described the investigation where she estimated people's audience
size. I want you to think about a time when you
posted a specific message or shared a photo on Facebook. What
was that message, and how many of your friends do you
think actually saw that exact post? And finally, what percent of
your friends do you think saw the post? The results of
Mora's investigation we reveal a little bit later in the course.
But just so you know, there's no right or wrong answers
for these. Keep your guesses in mind, and then you can
compare them to the results that Mora found in her study. Write
about your message or your post here and then enter two numbers
here and here. And there's no need to include a percent sign.